we need to build a weather service for
water yet until we collectively demand
accountability the incentives to fund it
will not exist the first time I spoke at
a conference was here at Ted eight years
ago fresh out of grad school little did
I know that in those few minutes on
stage I was framing the questions I was
going to be asked for the next decade
and like too many 20-somethings I
expected to solve the world's problems
more specifically the world's water
problems with my technology I had a lot
to learn
it was seductive believing that our
biggest water quality problems persist
because they're so hard to identify and
I presumed that we just needed simpler
faster and more affordable sensors I was
wrong while it's true that managing
tomorrow's water risks is going to
require better data and more technology
today we're barely using the little
water data that we have our biggest
water problems persist because of what
we don't do and the problems we fail to
acknowledge there's actually little
question about what today's water data
is telling us to do as a species we need
to conserve more and we need to pollute
less but today's data is not going to
help us forecast the emerging risks
facing businesses and markets it's
rapidly becoming useless for that it
used to carry more value but it's never
actually told us with any real accuracy
how much water we have or what's in it
let's consider the past decade of water
usage statistics from each of the g20
nations now what these numbers do not
tell you is that none of these countries
directly
measures how much water they use these
are all estimates and they're based on
outdated models that don't consider the
climate crisis nor do they consider its
impact on water in 2015
Chennai India sixth largest city was hit
with the worst floods it had seen in a
century today its water reservoirs are
nearly dry it took three years to get
here three years of sub average rainfall
now that's faster than most nations
tabulate their national water data
including the US and although there were
forecasts that predicted severe
shortages of water in Chennai none of
them could actually help us pinpoint
exactly when or where this was going to
happen this is a new type of water
problem because the rate at which every
aspect of our water cycle changes is
accelerating as a recent UN warning this
month revealed we are now facing one new
climate emergency every single week
there are greater uncertainties ahead
for water quality it's rare in most
countries for most water bodies to be
tested for more than a handful of
contaminants in a year instead of
testing we use what's called a dilution
model to manage pollution now imagine I
took an Olympic sized swimming pool I
filled it with fresh water and I added
one drop of mercury that would dilute
down to one part per billion mercury
which is well within with the World
Health Organization considers safe but
if there was any unforeseen drop in how
much water was available less ground
water less stream flow less water in the
pool less dilution would take place and
things would get more toxic so this is
how most countries are managing
pollution they use this model to tell
them how much pollution is safe and it
has clear weaknesses but it worked well
enough when we had abundant water and
it's consistent weather patterns now
that we don't we're going to need to
invest
and develop new data collection
strategies but before we do that we have
to start acting on the data we already
have this is a jet fuel fire as many of
you may be aware jet fuel emissions
plane enormous role in climate change
what you might not be aware of is that
the US Department of Defense is the
world's largest consumer of jet fuel and
when they consume jet fuel they mandate
the use of the firefighting foam
pictured here which contains a class of
chemicals called Peethas nobody uses
more of this foam than the US Department
of Defense and every time it's used PFS
finds its way into our water systems
globally militaries have been using this
foam since the 1970s we know PFS causes
cancer birth defects and it's now so
pervasive in the environment that we
seem to find it in nearly every living
thing we test including us but so far
the US Department of Defense has not
been held accountable for PFS
contamination nor has it been held
liable and although there's an effort
underway to phase out these firefighting
foams they're not embracing safer
effective alternatives that are actually
using other PFS molecules which may for
all we know carry worse health
consequences so today government
accountability is eroding to the point
of elimination and the risk of liability
from water pollution is vanishing what
types of incentives does this create for
investing in our water future over the
past decade the average early-stage
global investment in early stage water
technology companies is totalled less
than 30 million dollars every year
that's point one two percent of global
venture capital for early-stage
companies and public spending is not
going up nearly fast enough and a closer
look at it reveals water is not a
priority in 2014 the US federal
government was
$11 per citizen on water infrastructure
versus 251 dollars an IT infrastructure
so when we don't use the data we have we
don't encourage investment in new
technologies we don't encourage more
data collection and we certainly don't
encourage investment in securing a water
future so are we doomed part of what I'm
still learning is how to balance the
doom and the urgency with things we can
do
because right Athene Berg and the
extinction rebellion don't want our hope
they want us to act so what can we do
it's hard to imagine life without a
weather service but before modern
weather forecasting we had no commercial
air travel there it was common for ships
to be lost at sea and a single storm
could produce a food shortage once we
had radio and telegraph networks all
that was necessary to solve these
problems was tracking the movement of
storms and that laid the foundation for
a global data collection effort one that
every household and every business
depends upon today and this was as much
the result of coordinated and consistent
data collection as it was the result of
producing a culture that's a greater
value in openly assessing and sharing
everything that it could find out and
discover about the risks we face a
global weather service for water would
help us forecast water shortages it
could help us implement rationing well
before reservoirs run dry it could help
us detect contamination before it
spreads it could protect our supply
chains secure food supplies and perhaps
most importantly it would enable the
precise estimation of risk necessary to
insure against it we know we can do this
because you've already done it with
weather but it's going to require
resources we need to encourage greater
investment in water investors venture
capitalists a portion of your funds and
Folio should be dedicated to water
nothing is more valuable and after all
businesses are gonna need to understand
water risks in order to remain
competitive in the world we are entering
aside from venture capital there are
also lots of promising government
programs that encourage economic
development through tax incentives a new
option in the u.s. that my company is
using is called Opportunity Zones they
offer favorable tax treatment for invest
in capital gains and designated
distressed and low income areas now
these are areas that are also facing
staggering water risks so this creates
crucial incentives to work directly with
the communities who need help most and
if you're not looking to make this type
of investment but you own land in the US
did you know that you can leverage your
land to conserve water quality
permanently with a conservation easement
you can assign the perpetual right to a
local land trust to conserve your land
and set specific water quality goals and
if you meet those goals you can be
rewarded with a substantial tax discount
every year how many areas could our
global community protect through these
and other programs they're powerful
because they offer the access to real
property necessary to lay the foundation
for a global weather service for water
but this can only work if we use these
programs as they are intended and not as
mere vehicles for tax evasion when the
conservation easement was established
nobody could anticipate how ingrained in
environmental movement's corporate
polluters would become and we've become
accustomed to companies talking about
the climate crisis while doing nothing
about it
this is undermined the legacy and the
impact of these programs but it also
makes them right for reclamation why not
use conservation easements as they were
intended to set and and reach ambitious
conservation goals why not create
opportunity
in Opportunity Zones because
fundamentally water security requires
accountability accountability is not
corporate polluters sponsoring
environmental groups and museums those
are conflicts of interest accountability
is making the risk of liability too
expensive to continue polluting and
wasting our water we can't keep settling
for words it's time to act and we're
better to start than with our biggest
polluters particularly the US Department
of Defense which is taxpayer funded who
and what are we protecting when US
soldiers their families and the people
who live near US military bases abroad
are all drinking toxic water global
security can no longer remain at odds
with protecting our planet or our
collective health our survival depends
on it
similarly agriculture in most countries
depends on taxpayer-funded subsidies
that are paid to farmers to secure and
stabilize food supplies these incentives
are a crucial leverage point for us
because agriculture is responsible for
consuming 70% of all the water we use
every year fertilizer and pesticide
runoff are the two biggest sources of
water pollution
let's restructure these subsidies to
demand better water efficiency and less
pollution
finally we can't expect progress if
we're unwilling to confront the
conflicts of interest that suppress
science that undermine innovation and
discourage transparency it is in the
public interest to measure and to share
everything we can learn and discover
about the risks we face in water reality
does not exist until it's measured it
doesn't just take technology to measure
it it takes our collective will thank
you
[Applause]